hey everybody and welcome to the wildest
wild ride of them all you guys have been
begging for this guest since the podcast
first started and i'm telling you it is
a good one man it's manny pwigg he's a
legend of messing around with apex
predators and such a dear friend of mine
he's helped me accomplish many
ridiculous feats so
safe to say i'm hard as a rock for this
one and full disclosure just a little
bit later tonight i will actually be
hard as a rock because i'm going to
treat myself to a blue chew tablet and
what's that it's a chewable tablet that
has the same active ingredient as both
viagra and cialis except of course it's
chewable and only a fraction of the
price yeah dude so how do you get it
well you go to bluechew.com which means
that you don't have to go into any
physical in-person awkward doctor visit
now you just consult with one of the the
medical providers on bluetooth.com it's
very simple it's very easy and then
you're ready to go now if you use the
promo code stevo while you're doing that
guess what you get an entire month's
supply of this very very fun chewable
tablet and all you have to pay is five
bucks for shipping so dude get ready to
have some fun go to bluetooth.com use
the promo code stevo and dude
absolutely free an entire month's supply
all you gotta pay is five bucks for
shipping so head on over to
bluetooth.com and get ready to have some
good
good fun and now let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen
manny pig
yeah dude
right on manny yes i'm glad to be here
yeah dude this is my co-host scott
you've met him before
yes and up at the front we have the
gorgeous paul briskey hey there manny we
just met how are you
it's good definitely gorgeous here oh
thank you
yeah dude so
people have been begging for you manny
they then that we started this podcast
what about a year and a half ago
and uh and they've been saying oh get
manny on there they want to hear all the
crazy
stories so whoa
yeah when you came to the show in dania
people were freaking out going ape [ __ ]
over you yeah it was a good show
definitely i enjoyed it
well one thing thank you um
how did you first
uh hear about jackass and the that we
wanted to film with you
oh dude that was a story i'm at the
native village
and they go manny these jackass guys
they're really bad i mean they're really
like stupid guys they do a lot of stupid
things and they're looking for you they
want you to be on their show and they
got like they were saying all right some
people are saying i really don't
recommend it you know i might ruin your
reputation
i come here but it's jackass guys yeah
okay yeah they're really crazy
they said you guys were dumb and crazy
and did a lot of dumb things okay
once then when i met up with you guys
finally i started to get catch on to
what's really going on
stevo's to get ran over by an airboat
and i tell him well you got to duck real
low so you know get real low so when
airboat comes over he doesn't hit you
then i realized that stevo got his head
up high enough so the airboat would hit
it hit him in the head so i said man
i'm starting to figure the idea is to
get the airboat to run over here
to avoid the problem and then naxo comes
over there and uh he wants to get bit by
a rattlesnake
and he wants to get bit by rattlesnake
he thought well you know just you know
take me to hospital give me an annie
venom and we're good let's go to the bar
tonight and i said no dude that thing
bites you you might have your arm
amputated kind of like this
[Laughter]
you want to get bit by an eastern back
rattle thing about that big around so i
said well that was insane and the next
thing you know sibo was going to put a
worm up his nose what do you think about
this i think it's a bad idea maybe
should clean the worm
because there's a lot of you know
diseases in the dirt and everything you
know we don't want to get steeple sick
it's not a good idea and then and then
uh tremaine goes nah he'll put it up it
smells dirt and all
he had seen that was too it's got his
worm going through
of his nose and not his mouth like that
you know yeah
the worm but i thought i was just
cracking up you know it's just like too
much
that was the first day that we've ever
filmed with manny
and i'll never forget it we met it was a
place in the everglades where we filmed
all that yeah and so there's this
everglades like special like tourism
park and and we're in the parking lot
you know i'll just we just arrived
getting ready to set up manny's standing
there knoxville's standing there off in
the distance this family notices us you
can see they're very excited and they
come walking over
and they
i think they're gonna freak out they
think they're freaking out over
knoxville they walk right past knoxville
straight to manny manny oh it's so great
i can't even believe it i'm thinking man
like knoxville was all prepared to be
the big the big deal they walked right
past it was so funny and uh they were
all excited to see manny i thought man
manny's a really big deal
this is this is great
and and i found out later
that that
because we had filmed with sharks on the
first season and i got bitten and the
people that took us filming with those
nurse sharks we were super upset and i
was just like we get we need someone
who's crazy to film with and they they
saw you on animal planet and the way
they described they said here we see
this guy on animal planet manny and he's
lifting alligators out of the water like
swimming with alligators at night riding
sharks all over the place but the fact
that he was doing all of that while
wearing a speedo
[Laughter]
the speedo they said the speedo got you
the job
definitely
uh yeah after that it was just like i
don't know you guys took me to your
family you know big time manny how long
were you doing jackass before it became
wild boys like did did you come on
during the tv show or during the movies
the tv show came out during the tv show
and then during the movie and then once
wow boys came on they had me on all the
time
uh basically i got more exposure from
wow boys than anything i've ever done in
my life let's put it this way
the key for me right there yeah and like
people going wild for you at steve's
show and danny or donnie or whatever
does that happen to you often like if
you go to the grocery store or
do you get recognized often still to
this day yeah yeah i still got people
here and there but especially when you
get you know the right crowd you know
sure i mean i did uh shark week yeah i
did animal planet a bunch of episodes i
did outdoor channel and everything but
the wow boys was the biggest exposure
like uh eighty ninety percent of people
come up to me is because i saw the wild
voice for sure i got a question uh
some of the footage that i saw i'm not
sure if it was on if it aired anywhere
but the the one of you grabbing the lion
by the tail that was on wow boys that
was on wild boys
what's the story behind that why why
grab a line by the tail what
it's like a you know it's a
like a manhood thing like
here's the thing that's
a side thing i think for for manny to be
able to tell this story we have to
reveal a secret it's not even a secret
about wild boys but um
while
with jackass we were very very honest we
had integrity we never tried to deceive
the audience that was jackass but with
wild boys we took liberties to pretend
that we were in africa when actually we
were filming in california
and it wasn't because we we wanted to to
lie to the audience you know in fact
when we went to go film the pilot for
for wild ways in south africa we brought
that two-man zebra suit and we wanted to
go on safari and have a lion there and
we quickly found out that a lion in the
wild on safari in africa you don't get
in a [ __ ] zebra suit and [ __ ] try
and play around with that thing now
so there are a lot of situations like
that and so every time that we filmed
interacting with a lion
like every time we were always
pretending that we were in africa but in
fact we were in california at a place
called hollywood animals
and so
the lion that manny grabbed by the tail
i mean you could say
it was a tame lion but there's really no
such thing as taming a lion you know you
look at siegfried and roy their their
tigers messed that dude up
um but but in any case it wasn't that
didn't happen in africa
no no it happened but the messiah used
to pull
grab a line by the tail on a lion hunt
and the guy that did that he's the one
that would get all the all the women
would come after him he was like the the
cool guys so it was a cool thing to do
you know you know copying another
culture like a messiah in africa on my
sideline hunters and grabbing the line
by the tail was that the first and only
time you did that
yes
also for the record it's still a cool
thing idea to grab any lion by the tail
you know you grab a uh domesticated zoo
line whatever tail he's liable turn
around and bite you in half yeah we
loaded fully clawed and the people there
said you're on your own
yeah what's the animal you don't [ __ ]
with at all that you're like i'm not
doing i'm not filming anything with that
like they're too unpredictable or too
dangerous
i don't think manny has one yeah is
there even one i haven't had a problem
maybe that i haven't
i might think twice about it it's like a
hippo
okay
yeah i mean alaska we swim with wild
killer whales and wild grizzly bears so
you know they
killed whale will do
you know they kill everything in the
ocean every living creature out there
they kill so those things are very prone
to killing so swimming sound like that
it's a it's a very big gamble let's put
it that way but when we swim with the
the killer whales in alaska they
remember like we saw these wild killer
whales and and manny's so excited he
just basically jumps off the boat and
starts swimming towards them everybody
was freaking out but what we discovered
was that killer whales don't want to be
around people so as much as you swam
towards them they went away right like
i think what happened is the guy dropped
me off in their path and they weren't
right through me and one of them came
like three feet from me underwater
that one of them did uh check you know
water was so dirty you couldn't see
anything that was right up on you
remember when we told chris yeah they
were jumping behind the boat behind them
almost like in this aquarium type of
deal yeah
so no they're they're very unpredictable
let's put it this way they uh i mean
somebody told me that a part of them
attacked the blue whale biggest thing
that ever lived and they they destroyed
it right and they they get another
anything that kills a blue whale is
nothing to mess with right and and they
can kill a great white shark too right
yeah they they kill them no problem they
roll them in on their back and bite out
their stomach and kill them yeah so you
know there's no shark or anything they
can match up to
to kill will yeah the blue
the blue whale's tongue weighs as much
as an elephant that's pretty fascinating
fact yeah yeah that's something funny 20
20 elephants oh really
fact of the day yeah it's the biggest
animal bigger than any dinosaurs ever
lived the blue holy [ __ ] and paul asks
is there any animal you won't [ __ ] with
he's like well the killer whale and and
he swam towards the
killer whale i only got within three
feet of that one yeah
yeah you become a real man when you grab
a hippo by the balls manny
i don't know at this point in my life i
may not want to try that you know
yeah do you get do you get nervous when
you're doing a pod over or like uh with
a bunch of crocodiles or alligators and
you can't see like i've seen some of the
stuff you've done in the swamp at night
like i i would never get into that kind
of situation
it could be a little problem when
there's a lot of them and you can't see
them i've done it before
where you've got a feel for them that's
that's the most dangerous thing you can
do same thing with sharks you want to be
able to see them even though i swim in
dirty water for sharks it's not a good
idea and it's not a good idea get with
alligators you can't even see them i
usually keep my hands real low so if a
bump wanna bump their bellies not their
open mouth but why wouldn't why wouldn't
they go after you
when they go after everything that's in
their water
manny's answer to this question is
hysterical and you know what i've been
sleeping in my rv for the last few days
down here at my warehouse facility in
san diego and even though i have a
shower in my rv i have not used it
because i don't need to because i'm
wearing native deodorant this stuff is
so awesome man it has no aluminum or
parabens it's purely natural i can
understand all of the ingredients and
it's never been tested on animals it's
just a good product from a good company
that makes you smell good and i really
want you to try it because it's awesome
and because you'll be supporting the
podcast so get into this great deodorant
at
native d e o dot com slash devo again
that's native d e o dot com slash stevo
or use the promo code stevo and you get
20 off your first order again this stuff
is fantastic there's 10 different scents
my favorite is eucalyptus and mint
that's because lux stole my coconut and
vanilla but hey that's cool because all
the scents are awesome so yeah support
the podcast smell good and feel good
about supporting this awesome company go
to
nativedeo.com
devo thanks so much and now why don't
these animals attack manny
they have gone after me
i got bitten by sharks like four
different types so they do go after you
not too many i have a good record of a
good professional record but the amount
of times i've done it i have taken some
good hits definitely
that's so good
um
when uh
the the first time that we ever swam
with sharks with manny was uh
it that it was november of 2000 when we
first met we did the worm and knoxville
tried to get bit by the rattlesnake and
we did the airboat with alligator and
then it was
january of the next year the first time
we did a shark dive and this was for
hammerheads and manny was
treading water it outside just in the
ocean by the boat he's in the water for
like six hours i think it was just
holding barracuda and with his knife and
just chopping up the barracuda to get
the water all bloody and get the sharks
to come
i couldn't even believe how how long
how much time you spent doing that and
then when the when the sharks came we
got it we swam with them we thought okay
that was cool
but then somebody had the idea oh why
don't we get stevo on the boat and and
take barracudas which are all cut in
half and strap them all over stevo and
get him in the water
to swim with barracuda while he has chum
strapped all over him and uh there's
certain people on the boat really didn't
like that idea they got very upset i got
in the water like i was with manny and
uh and everything worked out okay then
later when when the footage came out on
tv i was eating dinner with my dad and
dad says
how can it possibly be safe to swim with
great hammerhead sharks while you have
chum strapped all all over your body
and i said
dad
manny was there
like it was perfectly fine it's not safe
it is not safe to do that none of the
stuff that
we did out there was really that safe
that's the whole idea it was a
hammerhead or dangerous
but it felt like you had this
invincibility around manny like if he
was there
would have got bit really bad that's the
worst scenario could have happened
yeah no paul you're absolutely right
like i
manny always instilled in me a sense of
security a sense of invincibility like i
really like if if manny was around i
generally felt completely unaccountable
for anything that i did around sharks or
any other apex predator and and it's
four sense of security
holy [ __ ]
they call that a false sense of security
yes everything is fine
nothing is fine nothing is good
right but i think that i think that that
uh you know when you ask manny does he
get nervous you know i i watched this uh
this academy award-winning documentary
called free solo where the guy climbs up
this el capitan with no ropes and you
can tell from watching that documentary
that this guy is just a different type
of dude like whatever like part of your
brain has fear this guy like doesn't
have that like part of his brain
activated and i think that manny's very
much like that where he's just a
different dude he's set up differently
and he's comfortable around and i think
that's why manny has been able to
to do all this stuff for so long and not
get killed by these animals because if
they can sense the fear if the animals
sense your fear then they're gonna pick
up on that and you're gonna get more
attacked right and manny manny's just
comfortable around apex predators and
that's why he's been so successful
around them and i think that i was
successful around them because
manny gave me that sense of comfort
yeah we were very comfortable in there
almost too comfortable
i mean with sharks venomous snakes
alligators uh everything i mean we had
you in the middle of the gulf of mexico
a bunch of sharks attacking on a
surfboard
that was another magnificent good bad
ideas that's what i call them yeah these
are all good ideas and bad ideas at the
same time
that was when like a huge shark showed
up right that's the dusky shark shut up
oh wow giant dusky that's the first time
i've ever seen dusky's
and man they showed up and then i mean
their bite their bites were like 30
pounds of meat in one one bite you got a
map
enormous like that
how did you uh get bit by the
rattlesnake to lose your finger
well
again another those good ideas
pick up a rattlesnake without using any
kind of equipment whatsoever just bare
hands go in there and pick them up
like i did
you saw me do it before
yeah you do it all the time you just you
just put it on your on the back of its
head on the top of its head the cookie
yeah yeah
yeah that was another bad idea
it was great that's another bad idea i
mean that rattlesnake bites you
somebody's gonna die or miss a big party
okay there's no way there's no way when
a big diamondback bites you you don't
come out of that clean that's just no
way yeah you came out of it
you came out of it with the perma
shocker
yeah yeah
yeah
[ __ ] yeah dude that's real so yeah what
happens you go in there okay this is
another one of the many many
rattlesnakes put them on top of the head
and go for a grab i was off a half inch
when i did the the grab that thing made
a half a turn so both thanks in my
finger i said my brain radio you have a
serious serious problem right now i also
was like free to tell everybody you know
like okay the trip is ruined i picked up
look at the producer it got me
and he goes you gotta be kidding no i'm
holding it i said no
i'm bit
and everybody's like froze okay
let's run to the hospital
and then that was it you know
and i was like uh
i was praying i thought uh i might not
make it i mean my arm was swelling i was
trolling like a balloon at a high rate i
knew i knew i had gotten a lot a lot of
venom in me so you know it's uh kind of
like you know it's not a good idea to
pick up rattlesnake after rattlesync
after all saying if you do it once don't
do it again what was what was worse the
the rattlesnake
experience or the covet experience
man bitten by a rattlesnake or badly
hospitalized with covid those are two
bad situations but you know what else is
a really bad situation
having to take a dump without my hello
tushy bidet
might not sound that serious but it is i
hate pooping without it i mean i have a
shower and a toilet in my rv but it
doesn't have a tushy bidet and that
drives me crazy what is it it's the most
amazing device that you easily mount
onto your toilet when you get done with
a big sloppy crap you just twist that
dial and it blasts this refreshing
stream of water onto your butthole it's
like pressure cleaning your pooper and
i'm telling you it leaves you so
fresh so satisfied and you're saving the
environment because you're not using so
much toilet paper and i'm telling you
i'd like the whole time i've been living
on my rv i have not pooped i've got to
get home and use my tushy bidet and i
want you to try one too go to
hellotushy.com
that's going to get you 10 off of this
order and free shipping plus you'll be
supporting the podcast and your butthole
is going to be so happy i promise you
it's actually my favorite product that
i've ever been introduced to by this
podcast and i want you to try it so go
to hellotushy.com
stevo and that gets you 10 off your
order plus free shipping now i'm gonna
drive this rv home take a dump wash my
butthole and bone my girl and you are
going to listen to this awesome story
about rattlesnakes and covid
um because i know you got covered really
bad yeah i did i did i got covered what
happened with a covert it wasn't so much
a covert since i'm like 67 years old now
i got a prostate about that big
so
the cover cut that inflamed and next
thing no i wasn't going enough and i had
a horrible kidney pain and it was from
not being able to go enough also it's
getting dehydration in my kidneys and
all that so that's where
if i don't have a prostate problem my
cobra would not have been that bad but
coco is very unpredictable
i mean the best thing to do is once you
catch it you build a defense it's like
stevo
uh to me you look like you're immune to
every disease because in the planet you
know there's everybody's ever heard of a
kodak but then he's got a thousand
people hugging them every couple hours
thousands of people all right
and he's smiling and everything i go you
know this guy's not gonna you know he'll
be covered for breakfast you know so
it's so funny
yeah in this building culvert as you can
see coco does not exist in here they're
not allowed
yeah so that was awesome so because
covert was particularly bad because of
the prostate situation did that does
that mean that the corvette
was worse than the rattlesnake
they were both uh
once i got a catheter in me a tube
the the pain went away the rattlesnake
pain
lasted
for months and months
and it was never ending a constant pain
that just would not go away it is i mean
it took me forever my hand i couldn't
pick up a cup of coffee it would just
drop like that it was so weak wow so
devastated you know who knows what it
did to me what are you supposed to do
after you get bit by a rattlesnake like
what's the what's going through your
head are you do you
okay relax remain calm don't get your
blood pressure yeah
i was very calm very relaxed like usual
you know i told him to relax yeah i was
very relaxed laid back like this
and
go to the hospital don't go see a witch
doctor or anything like that go
to the hospital doctor
the people know what they're doing and
get that anti-venom and you as quick as
possible they were taking their time and
i was like dude this is a big
rattlesnake i need about 50 gallons of
anti-venom in me like right now
i was telling them in the hospital and
is it is it that day that your finger
gets amputated or is it like weeks later
they're like oh we gotta just take it
it was a month a month wow about a month
later
uh my brother-in-law came in the house
and saw me taking pieces of meat off the
finger and he looked at that dude that
is horrible you need to go to the doctor
right now when the doctor signed he goes
you ain't going home you need to go to
uh you need to lay in that bed right now
and you need to get that finger cut off
okay how about i can you cut it off
right now so you can get it over with
you know and then uh
and that was it and then they told me
well they can make it look pretty no no
i just want to be able to keep as much
of my hand as possible so i cut it here
and then took the skin back here and
ripped it around to this day it feels
like a finger's still there and it's not
i don't know
man feels like made out of rubber
it's not normal it doesn't have the
you know
i got gourd by boar here and i got a
missing tendon here too so this hand
ain't well either
how many animals have you been bitten by
uh let me see
four different types of shark uh
two types of rattlesnake pygmy and
western diamondback
and uh alligator once in the back and
wild boar
right here
in the leg you got my leg i got a hole
in my leg and i hold here the wall board
a bullet was coming out like this so
yeah yeah board is another bad animal to
mess with you know i mean it really
they're smart
and they will mess you up you get the
right boar it will put you in the
hospital if not kill you jesus how many
animals have you been bitten by steve we
used to keep a list of uh of animals
that but our list wasn't as because
manny only manny's list has higher
standards than ours
but i i
i keep i keep lists of movies i've seen
in different countries you guys keep
track of animals that have bitten you in
different countries you know before we
continue any further manny i want you to
tell everybody about the the great
tridents and spears and all of the
jewelry and the t-shirts and all this
great stuff that you make definitely
okay let's try ears of trident
a trident if anybody's just listening
only it's uh the great thing that
aquaman uses where it's like a big spear
but it's got three tips
and uh and you actually use these to
hunt right
to catch fish haunt whatever you want to
get with it it's mostly an aquatic
weapon it will design in ancient times
to catch fish
uh the roman gladiators use them on each
other and it goes into you know the
legendaries like you know poseidon and
all that had it and different things
like that but it is uh it's a beautiful
uh weapon for fishing the only people
ever used them in each other were roman
gladiators which is a bad idea you know
you don't want to get stuck with this
thing but it's historical you know
i bought one of these from you and i
have it on the wall in my house and i'm
so proud of it plus it's insane how
sharp you make it
yeah
it's thicker and heavier than this one
yeah yours is what we call the large
massive one this is the most common one
i move this is the fishing trident it's
a
half inch thick stainless steel plating
you're just three quarters and you can
really throw that you could you can
really throw that yeah you can throw
this at fish and catch fish with it all
day long how many in stock do you have
you can catch fish for this you can
survive
it's a nice thing to have how many do
you have in stock manny
i usually make them to order
and sometimes i have i got the boat show
coming up so i'm going to try to have a
few in stock
i also have here this is a medieval
polax this is a medieval knights useless
thing
uh to fight in the battlefield this is
an axe and one here and also a spear
so this is like i hand make all of these
this is out of three quarters
uh this
yeah you can hunt with a trident's got
more uses but if you like medieval stuff
you know and you want to go back in time
you know and play this kind of thing
these are very dangerous so
be careful playing with them where do
people get these if they want to if they
want to
contact you or
my instagram many point on instagram
all right and so so people
so there's no website they go to
mannypwig on instagram i am going to
have a website but you know you know me
i don't have it up yet
depending on helping me out with that
but it's right now it's just on
instagram
and i have uh
i got a
also made medieval knights like this one
here a stiletto and also put people's
names on them you know engrave them you
know they want their
their stuff i can put their names i got
all kinds of knives i got
i got i make fish hooks
see
his
name on it
people's name
tarp fish fishing donut tarpon fish
hooks i got stuff like that and
i got a t-shirt this one
and i don't know how i don't have one of
those t-shirts right there
yeah no what about them i gotta i gotta
have one of those t-shirts that you're
wearing i'm definitely going to get you
one steel no problem
and here this is wild boar i got a fish
skeleton this is a wild boar
since i you know
did you do all the artwork for that yeah
absolutely
wow man manny does all the artwork
right now and i got a large mouth bass
people who want to go bass fishing
fish in north america
so we'll send everybody to your
instagram
go
easy to find on there go on my instagram
and
i'll personally make sure you get
everything morgan where's morgan morgan
uh
my fiance she'll send out the stuff we
take a picture of the tracking number
make sure you get your stuff we take
care of everybody ah we love it i get my
web page i'll put it up because
sometimes when i'm busy i can't keep up
with it i think instagram is great and i
think uh i i would love it for everybody
to support you manny i i really think uh
i think it's a great idea i'm glad you
like that idea too
yeah i mean yeah that trident you have
steve is sick
how much does that trident go for
uh this one right now if your local 650
and for shipping at 700 for a fishing
trident if you're local but what about
if you're living in i said 700 if you're
not local 650 if you're local and then
can you put me down
can you put me down for one of those
tridents
for the shipping the shipping is a
hassle what uh we've made a sale manny
wants to try it out can you put me down
for one of those tridents i'll i'll
message you oh no problem put your name
on it i love it i engrave it i make it
by hand it'll all be done
and uh t-shirts are 35.
put me down for one of those two
no problem
uh stiletto like this is 400. now the
regular knights i make with all the fish
deck ratings on them those are 250.
hook necklace with your name on it is uh
100 bucks i'll engrave
your name or your girlfriend's name or
anyone on it it's stainless steel yeah
put paul for that one of those too
scott will take one of each and i'll
take uh
yeah i'll take a trident and a t-shirt
i'd love a trident too man yeah that's
two we got two sales all right yeah dude
you should sell a shirt with like your
hand on it like jerry garcia you know
yeah
i mean i i've always put something like
an animal on there i have very animal
oriented you know i am
yeah
you know dangerous wealth animals
especially all the animals that bit you
that would be sick i'm sure there's
every animal that bit manny yeah with
his hand in the middle
and the rattlesnake
yeah lemon shark he's going to say
something cool real quick
um i i wanted to
amen
with here with your fiance do you go to
the the titty bar
no no dude i haven't been to a titty bar
since i got a fiance
i remember when i'm around dude
yeah i remember when when uh and and
this is not disrespectful to your fiance
this is many years ago like like 20
years ago when i moved to l.a manny was
in la all the time and uh and we would
go to this this titty bar called crazy
girls and uh and manny and minnie has
this way of saying things where he's not
trying to be funny he's just super just
like matter-of-fact and and i i thought
it was so great manny said i go to the
titty bar like six or seven nights a
week
that was the office steve will go we go
out tonight and see if we'll go
meet me at crazy girls and when you go
in there the girls be fighting over
steel oh i don't know about all that
a couple of actual fights out there you
know i did i
i did call crazy girls in my office
and we go down the strip and everything
you know but that's not living in l.a
did you ever stop by stevo's rad
apartment
yes oh yes i stopped by that in sand
placement place
no no it was i don't think any human
being could live there it was a little
the place was i mean skateboard things
being smashed beer cans i mean it was
just a disaster beyond you could i don't
think any human being could live it i've
never seen anything like it manny would
rather be in like [ __ ] alligator waters
there's less bacteria and something that
alligator water
do you have any cool stories of going to
the apartment do you remember anything
i just remember every time i go in there
you know they broke this they broke that
and then uh you know i was thinking what
are the you know they're gonna the when
the owners of the place they see the
place you know
i'm really thinking what's gonna happen
here another time we went over there was
a party in stevo's house another place
and they're watching uh
the the skateboarder
danny way yeah yeah anyway whatever and
then uh the next door neighbors are
coming over and complaining about all
the noise and steel goes look just i
don't want to hear any company coming in
tv look danny wade is on or uh
variety whatever what's his name the
other one they're on he goes just come
in and watch the show make sure he knows
i'm getting out of here the cops are
coming over all the noise like flavors
you know i always had back then it was
like noise
music on loud all night long tv crowds
it was just like you know
a human being couldn't keep up with that
you know we were it was like it was
crazy days definitely definitely
definitely crazy i don't know what was
crazier the the
the at work or at
home it was all crazy all the time you
brought work
people how are these guys dude they're
on camera and off camera back in the day
there's just no difference were the
cameras rolling or not all kinds of
crazy things were happening 24 7. nobody
was safe you better lock your door at
night or you don't know what's going to
happen to you
yeah it was very very unsafe traveling
with a with a
jackass group i mean you know somebody
might take a dump in your pillow or
something like in the middle of night
you have no idea what's going to happen
so uh mandy do you remember when we went
to alaska on that trip where we were
swimming with the killer whales and uh
and and we
we made this was this was one i couldn't
believe we got this on tv we took a uh a
female
um salmon a big salmon fish and by by
running the finger down like the middle
of the bottom of the salmon they were
able to push all of the salmon eggs
out of the salmon and into my mouth so
they're about they filled my they filled
my mouth with uh just
jamming their finger down and all the
eggs fly into my mouth and then they
grab a male salmon and they do the same
thing with the male salmon and they run
their fingers down and and it was just
salmon [ __ ] they they there was so
much semen came out of this salmon and
just sprayed my whole face and filled my
mouth with with fish yeah yeah these
salmon had also been dead out of the
water after they died
longer washed up on the bank they
weren't they weren't they were like half
rotten you know what i mean they stunk
they were already
i mean you couldn't live
even if it was cooked that sandwich
cooked i wouldn't eat it no way no way
one of those salmons i found on the bank
of that river laying out there like that
there
there were uh
was cracking cracking up man but he goes
i'm gonna save and incubate these salmon
eggs
back in the water yeah jesus did you
spit or swallow steve
yeah good question i'm reasonably sure
that i was a spitter that day
manny do you have any special memories
from the wild boys that stand out to you
my favorite stuff is the wow boys
uh stuff like all of the wildlife you
know assuming the alligators daytime and
nighttime
uh swimming with the sharks and also the
killer whales and the bears in alaska
swimming with the getting in the water i
had never got face to face with grizzly
always wanted to and of course i took
advantage of the water i got into the
water and the grizzly came up at me we
told the people out there the game and
fishing were studying bears they didn't
know what we were we said you know we're
just you know like biologists was like
over here to study the bears i got in
the water and mixing no we're just
trying to confront the bears and get get
a situation
yeah the holy [ __ ] and an encounter um
yeah that was
some of my favorite stuff there's so
much of it though you know the snakes
were fun a lot of funny stuff too man
right a lot of the stuff was it wasn't
all animals lots of it was just
incredible
incredibly funny yeah is there anything
on that never made the i think what was
special was when we would actually find
animals in the wild in their
natural habitat because like grizzly
bears for example right so much of it
was like okay we're gonna pretend we're
in california we're gonna pretend we're
in africa but we're actually in in
california you know and and like or
maybe we are legitimately in some other
country but
we're gonna we're gonna
set up this shoot right here and they're
gonna bring an animal in a cage and then
let it out of the cage like sort of
makes it make it appear as if we
discovered the animal in in nature when
really we didn't there was a lot of just
filming out there they're so nice
remember that bear did both you and uh
chris got inside the sleeping bag
bit uh chris in the butt okay yeah
yeah
chris had a uh a black bear on his list
of on his bite list he's a pretty good
one but
that's that's a dangerous a black bear
will go crazy on you
at any moment i'm gonna rip your head
off at any second you get between him
and his food
yeah that was the toughest thing for me
is that we spent so much time in zoos
and they had all these like transporting
animals to come and pretend as if they
were in the wild when they weren't like
i i didn't i didn't really like that but
like manny said man when we when we
found the grizzly bears in the wild you
know and the the killer everything that
we found in the wild like we found the
[ __ ] silverback gorillas in rwanda i
mean unbelievable what was that
experience like that i wasn't there but
that was in a while yeah that doesn't
rip your head off
we had we had the [ __ ]
the the silverback gorilla
babies in between us and the [ __ ] uh
and and the adults how big are they if
we were in between the babies and the
adults that then we would be so dead
huge yeah that that was that was
probably the most incredible thing that
there were you like to pull it on your
arm it'll come off okay he could rip
your arm right off one
that thing is incredibly powerful animal
no question about it what was so cool
about about any time that we shot with
manny you know how uh
how like jackass and wild boys they
would say these stunts are performed
under the supervision of professionals
right like manny counted as a
professional so as long as we had manny
with us no matter what the [ __ ] idea we
come up with we're allowed to do it
because it's under the supervision of
manny who's the professional what's your
profession
my profession is uh you know
i self-educated i have a degree my
profession is i just have a reputation
i don't have any other stuff my rubbish
this isn't going to put you in a
dangerous situation possibly
come out make it alive out of it that's
what i'm going to do the worst situation
i could put with a wild animal that's
that was the whole idea and then
hopefully everything will come out good
you know nobody gets you know too hurt
or something like that right like when
when when manny like the first year we
ever filmed with manny and and knoxville
says okay i want to get bit by
rattlesnake and manny says no that's not
you know like when manny says it's not
okay like he did
it's not [ __ ] okay and if manny says
it is okay that doesn't mean it's
[ __ ] okay
what else wasn't okay yeah did he ever
tell you not to do anything um i don't
think i was ever i mean i would always
listen to manny if manny said no don't
do that um but yeah what were there any
other things like it's always going to
be knocked out were you there when they
let the like the lioness for the
nintendo commercial
i don't know were you there when the
lion climbed atlantis got on top of
steeple on the tree yeah that could have
built steeple a hunter
holy clyde any any reaction it'll go
like this
and it'll
carve them up like there's no tomorrow
the land
those lands are extremely extremely
dangerous so one land expert says
when you don't put me in with a bottle
of race lion bottle fed he says give me
a wild lion he goes the one that'll kill
you is a bottle raised lion because he's
at one point he loses total fear of you
and if he turns on you he'll
they have a dominance thing the animals
do so just like what happened to the
sigmund freud guy
the segment guy
[Laughter]
i read an article on them they knew that
every minute they're around them all day
long they were you know it's a dangerous
animal there's no such thing as a safe
uh
pet one guy i remember i think this
girlfriend stepped in line still the
line bitter in her leg and she had to go
straight to the hospital yeah that got
to happen
but yeah i mean that's what the show is
about is that funny comedy and extreme
danger and funny and gross all at one
time and he gets it i have a question
that i really want to ask i'm scared to
ask it but
um are eastern diamondback rattlesnakes
more
deadly than western diamondback
rattlesnakes
i some people told me yes
some people told me that western's more
likely to bite you i've heard back and
forth all i know is they're very closely
related they both got that hemotoxin
some neurotoxin poison in them
and either one
will kill you some somebody told me the
eastern may be a little more toxic
but both of them will kill you i mean
okay
okay so really it's it's a worse well
you know what she was really bad that
little rattlesnake in california
southern pacific
that we remember we played around with
that thing bites you you'll be bleeding
out of your eyes and out of your ears
and out of your nose it dissolves your
brain that thing is probably one of the
most deadly snakes in the world the the
one you find around l.a that rattle sink
out there but
they're everywhere in [ __ ] l.a they
they're [ __ ] everywhere and the more
they want to get bit by that thing
you will go into convulsions that thing
is horrific horrific snake to get bit by
blue was it was that the snake that you
had on your tick tock maybe i mean i
don't [ __ ] know but but i didn't know
there's rattlesnakes all over the place
and the more that california gets like
super dry
like which it is like they they they
come more into where the people are to
find water
so like do you see mac you see
rattlesnakes more and more often and
like i i honestly personally don't even
[ __ ]
give a [ __ ] like it's i only care about
wendy my dog wendy so
my question is if you see anyone in york
just smash them
i'm not gonna do that either but um but
what uh what can i do
for my dog wendy
they could kill your dog very fast they
have rattlesnake courses yeah they do
training where like if they hear the
shake they're like yeah get rid of that
rattlesink if you catch it throw it away
get rid of them off your property
anywhere near your dog do not i mean
your dog is a thousand times more
important than those reptiles so the
heck with those rattlesnakes you know
when it comes to i got i got my trident
there you go three at once yeah nature's
takes second place when it comes to
family uh your pet and everything no way
no way i'm not don't take any chances
with those things you know therefore
we're on the wilderness you want to take
your chances with and play with them
that's fine but no no no that's
parks in florida right now are thick
they're a lot more remember i hate to
just wait all day long to get them to
come in they'll they come in a lot
quicker now
yeah there's a lot more shark now that
never happened what do you think that
what do you think that's because
they there's no more heavy duty
commercial fishing for sharks like they
used to be so they you know of course
they were pounded they were overfished
now they're under fish so the population
has grown you know
man
they were scarce let's put it this way
here's a crazy question did you see our
jackass shark week where poopies got
bitten
i heard about it i didn't see it but i
heard what was he jumped into with a
water skiing it was so bad
it was [ __ ] awful it was absolutely
[ __ ] awful man what it was was the
idea was
to jump at the shark remember like happy
days back in uh you know whenever and
they said oh that happy days the tv show
they had gone for so long and they ran
out of ideas and then all of a sudden
they had the fonzie
fawns is jumping over the shark and then
now that they became a saying like oh
that tv show like went for too long and
it jumped the shark this is a funny joke
they put a a a water ski ramp in the
ocean and the idea and and poopies is
dressed up like the fawns with the
leather jacket and he's yeah cool i'm
the fonz
he's gonna he's gonna jump off the the
water ski ramp and land where all the
sharks are because we're throwing all
the meat we're throwing all the meat
right in the landing area and these are
caribbean reef sharks they were [ __ ]
climbing all over each other to eat them
i saw a leaf i saw a [ __ ] leaf land
on the water and it got swarmed
they were so aggressive no i i could
have told you i was going to happen
i got bit in the leg by a carbon reshark
in a feeding frenzy they're really bad
and uh what happened is when they go on
a frenzy
attack and bite everything and go crazy
they will eat you alive they will eat
you alive i mean it was it was it was
insane man it was insane like with it
and we were losing light so it was dusk
which is the worst time to to do
something like this they're going to
attack way more at dusk and where the
when like we were throwing all the all
the chum throwing all these pieces of
meat right where uh in front of the job
where he's gonna land so every time
something lands on that water it's food
and it's it's food i thought they fed
they just so we're conditioning them
i could have told you that that was
going to happen i could have told you
what's going to happen
you know i have a a rule around sharks
try to stay up current of the blood
where is down current is the one who's
going to get bit yeah but he landed
they were biting everything and landing
in so when he landed just in the sack of
food landing in the waterford so here we
go guys i don't remember i don't
remember once they're on fire i gotta
fill the bellies to make them leave
oh my god so
it was so bad man and i wish we had we
would have had you there but we could
have prevent if we had you then that i
bet that wouldn't have happened
for sure yeah
you know you want to got the action that
you wanted i mean i don't know if you
wanted the action that bad that's pretty
good
it's coming back slowly it's been four
months and and he's the only he still
can't surf and all he cares about in the
world is surfing and you know it
happened at poopies but it but it
it's shocking that it didn't happen to
me because we had an idea for me with
the dunk tank and you throw the meat at
the at the target and then when the meat
hits the target
the chair drops you into the ocean
underneath you know so you're throwing
all the meat it's a feeding frenzy and
then finally the meat hits the target
and it drops to the seat it was the same
exact [ __ ] thing that would have
happened to me
i mean i i could you can get somebody
put food in my hand and blindfold them
and the shark will take them out of the
hand do something scary like that
that's a that's a good stunt but but
that is almost like a sure you know
you're asking for especially with a
korean reshark's frenzy if you've done
it when they're not frenzy then yeah
they'll win when you hit the water
they'll run away from you but not when
they're when it's on fire like that yeah
normally you sharks when they're not
frenzied
they're scared of everybody and
everything because they want to survive
they're afraid of each other nobody
wants to get hurt out there they want to
kill and not be killed
so that's what happened but when they're
like that the the the hunger and the
ferocity overrides all their fear and
everything else they just go ballistic
they climb all over each other they bite
each other they just they bite and they
they bite first and ask questions later
yeah that's when i got bit in the leg
same thing was happening it was a ball
of sharks all biting everything inside
it was a mad house in there and i went
into the mad house and i got bit in the
leg that's how it happened it's like
what pawnee said you give him an inch
they'll take a mile
yeah no i'm really inspired that he that
guy's uh
the surface hurt like that man i know
it's it's
he gets well paid for that you know what
i mean something i i don't even know man
i i don't i don't even know what that
situation is but but i think it'll come
back it's coming back slowly but i think
it'll come back and again
his foot or his hand what's messed up
it's his hand
right on the hand it's his uh he's
right-handed but it's his left hand
yeah well bethany hamilton is still uh
surfing after being armed bit off by
tiger shark in hawaii and she's surfing
in circles
she's paddling
i know she still searches it's hard to
do it i mean it ain't just that she lost
the whole arm to here i know it's a
tiger
yeah tiger listen sharks are no joke
they're not misunderstood or anything no
these are deadly creatures that live in
the ocean and they kill for a living
okay including things that live on land
and things that live in the ocean no
we're not in their fruits yeah you know
you we are part of the food supply if
you're in the water you are that you as
you can see right there there's no such
thing as uh no they they eat what's in
the water
and what falls in the water okay don't
don't go there
yeah
they're
nothing misunderstood about that
besides the rattlesnake did you ever
think you're in a situation where you're
like all right this is it i'm done
sure i mean when i got credited by wild
boar i don't know if he's gonna give me
some hallucious infection he's gonna
kill you about three days later
he's got all these diseases
and also the blood he got an argument
had to hold it like this i was bleeding
out like there's no tomorrow trying to
stop the it finally coordinated and
stopped but you're bleeding out and i'm
thinking okay i need to go to clinic and
get antibiotics or the next day i took
antibiotics everything i never got an
infection but yeah when the alligator
bit me in the back that's another thing
you get by now you can get an infection
but he just put 12 scratches on my back
if you ever had him got hold of my arm
he would have tore off he got me in a
bad angle
so he bit the wetsuit and slid the
wetsuit
away from me so he put like 12 scratches
on my back and a bruise here so he
wasn't able to get a good
you know
more like this that type of bite gotcha
did you see a good grip on it did you
see recently i'm not sure where it was
but it was some uh alligator handler
like uh it was was was bitten and and
the alligator got her yeah the girl and
the alligator got her hand and one of
the tourists like jumped on the
alligator and saved her and it was
rolling like
what do you think when you see that
and she kept her hand and she's very
very fortunate i've kept their hand
because once he bites he does this the
hand comes off what happened she went
under she wasn't careful enough to get
the hand way underneath here
yeah you know that's my specialty always
going i never got bit by an alligator
confrontation
you keep that hand low and make sure but
if you're not paying attention it goes
in
go get it you gotta put it here i took a
guy diving one time and he's swimming on
the surface his mask was all [ __ ] up i
picked up an alligator up
alligators at his mouth open i was
underneath him and i go
i gotta swim in and put his hand right
in the alligator's mouth
the guy ping ping ping ping ping but a
bunch of like look like bullet holes all
in the hand that's the only guy i ever
took out there he got bit by an
alligator wow
first aid bit yeah but why didn't the
why did the crocs go after you like or
the alligators on the on when you're
climbing the rope with like they just
went after the meat why wouldn't they
just because i think they they they were
manny was there i think what it was was
that those crocodiles are captive they
were fed chicken like constantly like
they're used to the chicken like so when
you present them with chicken that's
what they want that's what they're going
to go for and yeah if you give them a
chicken and then you take your chicken
with put your hand he'll take your hand
but the chicken being the closest to him
my calculation was that we're gonna grab
the chicken and miss stevo's butt that's
one of the funniest [ __ ] things manny
ever said he says and it's in the movie
it says if an alligator gets a hold of
stevo stevo will relax
and hopefully the alligator will release
him
for sure
like that guy when he got bit in the
hand i knew it was under i said i just
backed away from the alligator and i was
hoping the elegant alligator released
and swim back into the bottom of
or the quarry
alligator by jimmy says relax
relax and pray yeah
yeah
unless you're getting eaten alive you
know it's a different thing but normally
if you're messing with an alligator and
he bites when he has an escape route he
might let you go
if you've got a good grip on him and you
got him on land or something like that
but he's got deep water to let go he may
let go and take off into the deep water
if not he may never let you go damn
where does it come from
he has no rules he does what he wants
yeah where you're like uh
your fearlessness or at least
comfortable comfortability around these
animals where does that come from do you
grow up like just messing around with
animals and
climbing through swamps and stuff
it's a gift of god that i got when i was
a little boy
i asked him for he gave me the gift to
interact with all kinds of predators
that's where it comes from
who wins in the street fight you
crocodile dundee or steve irwin
dude uh i really don't want to get in a
street light with anybody you know
but
i mean there's no it's not a good idea i
mean you know i don't you know well i
mean those guys are cool
i don't want to hurt me i don't want to
hurt them but you know street fight
i don't know they would want to get in
the street fight anyway so but dundee's
got that big knife i think yeah yeah
i got something too
but yeah yeah that's kind of true i just
got to try this
he's got a big knife i got a traitor all
right so you would take him i think
so so what uh what are you spending your
time doing these days mostly are you
still filming with the outdoor channel
no no i haven't done uh somebody bought
the network and they ended the shows i
did five years with them
yeah i was getting pulled on the outdoor
channel it's probably a good thing that
it ended i mean i was getting invited
oh yeah you're kidding yeah okay
basically we'll go in the woods and do
whatever what are we gonna do let me see
what we find today uh producer no what's
up no there's no plan let's go out there
and see what happens and then we'll
build the story around whatever happens
that was my idea we'll just we'll make a
show out of anything yeah let's just
uh yeah no mostly my artwork i'm fixing
i went diving not too long ago i need to
get back in condition and start doing
some more diving
uh i want to get back into doing some
hand fishing i'm going to do
try to
catch different types of fish by hand i
like to primitive fishing i want to get
into that uh yeah i just want to get my
work and back into diving but marvel is
good i i like it it's worked out for me
i don't want to go one more
shark dive and make it the last one you
know what i mean where you end up being
retired instead of you retiring from it
you know one wrong move out there
one can end it for you yeah i'm doing
shark
yeah and it's good pay i may do
something
but you know i've done so much of it so
much it's a repeat of a repeat of the
same you know it's just going out there
and you know playing russian roulette
every day
you know
and and your fiance morgan she uh does
her music
so you spent a lot of time with her
doing her shows
uh well she does music morgan
morgan
manny's trying to show off
yeah
it's it's okay man but she's a singer
yeah yeah she plays piano and all that
stuff nice
yeah
she play she does some singing backup
singing but she's very good keyboarders
she plays with some really good bands in
florida and yeah she's busy next month
october she's booked up a lot of piano
gigs and everything uh she's got a good
presence and she's terrific on the piano
and keyboard okay
super cool man how do we how do people
find uh her to her schedule
morgan yeah
come over here i've been calling you
yeah
sit down what's going on just sit down
over here
i'm asking you about morgan from the
show that disappeared yeah i was telling
him about your keyboard and your uh
piano and all that stuff she's been
playing since the age of five uh
and uh she's got plenty of performances
coming up here in florida in october how
do people find your uh performance
schedule
i gotta get my calendar let me get you
wanted to know my my performance
schedule
well some of them they're all mostly uh
their country clubs are private uh
yeah link to some kind of a schedule
how did you meet how'd you meet her
manny
i was in uh club one night and she was
playing uh the keyboard
yeah and a little and then i had uh
i was talking to her and everything and
i said man you know just a good looking
girl and all that so and i had some
pictures in
my car brought out some photographs of
some of the stuff from me and the
alligators uh i think we went out to
dinner and uh india restaurant
and then some friends
they were all hippies yeah so i came up
outside and i had my spears showing them
they hit me the spears i make right
outside the restaurant and then i took
her to swim with the alligators ah
that's that's what it is
there was a ten-foot alligator and she
was very comfortable you know you know
the false sense of security like you get
[Music]
there's a temporary alligator inside
underneath the cover that went under a
trail and i told her to pull the
alligator's tail and she pulled the
august tail i'll turn around and became
the face so i got okay now it's time to
back up
i told her it's a big ten foot of big
white head came up there like that you
know how did you square this hot chick
oh i tried to feed her to an alligator
yeah
i don't want to get bit by a
alligator rattlesnake anything i don't
want anything to happen to morgan okay
simple as that okay so the old alligator
trick manny way to go
well manny thank you so much for for
doing this uh you know everybody's been
begging for it for you and and i love
you so much you're you're really like
family to me and i love that we got to
see each other just recently and you
know whenever i come to florida i love
to reach out to you and it's just good
that we that we have this relationship
that we've kept in touch for definitely
definitely stevo it's always good to see
you man uh we love you over here too
you're an awesome person yeah and you're
definitely man i i tell people about you
all the time oh yeah well you're you're
a conversation topic
always i don't think i can ever talk to
somebody for whatever reason your name
comes up whether it's your
professionalism the craziness the
dedication all the stuff anything your
dog comes up all the time you know
yeah
conversations come up bob i appreciate
you manny so much i love you and and i
hope everybody goes to your instagram
right now to to get themselves some of
your great art
uh thank you so much stevo thank you all
right right on manny take care right now
morgan yeah dude thank you
see you mandy
yeah dude
how killer was that
and
hey baby
[Music]
your call hey baby
yeah just wanted to let you know that
i'm getting on the road to come home and
poop
then blast my butt hole with the hello
tissue while i'm chewing on a blue chew
and then come with my fresh butthole and
my big boner to come
[ __ ] you
you lonka
yeah come bring it to me baby
all right cool i'm out of here see you
soon honey
yeah dude
later guys